the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the how do you do y'all
we're over here doing it in the night
pants Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media and I just want to say
before
I begin anything else I want to say
thank you for real thank you to every
single one of you out there thank you
for the love thank you for the support
thank you for the [__] jokes thank
you for all of it
um
yeah I'm not going to talk about this
now because I'm going to get emotional
about it and I'm really not ready to
talk about it but I promise you
everything that just happened and
honestly is still happening I'm still I
graduated from a walk or to a cane
um I haven't even started physical
therapy yet I got a long [__] year
ahead of me I have to live with blood
clots in my lungs uh as I know a lot of
you out there have dealt with this and
know how scary that [__] is
um but it went sideways and uh I'm here
I'm literally alive uh we're gonna get
into all that in another episode down
the line but uh the reason I want to say
this now is not only because I want to
thank everybody but because I don't know
it's a weird thing we recorded right up
into Byron Bowers we recorded
I don't know probably a few weeks before
I went in for surgery and just had
enough
episodes to get through uh what I went
through
um this is my first time doing a
honeydew again uh I did do a patreon
because it matters to me you guys pay
for that content and we have gone just
to the wire so I was able to get one in
but this is my first honeydew back
and like I said we're gonna do a full
episode with me in a few weeks somewhere
down the line I'll tell you the whole
story because there's some good [__] in
there too that's funny that I would
never want to keep to myself
but thank you again
um I genuinely love doing what I do for
a living and I love this show I love
this community and so many of you have
wanted to help out and I'm telling you I
don't I don't want money for medical
bills I don't want any of that [__]
subscribe to this show subscribe to this
show I want to see that number go up and
I want you to tell people about this
show because it matters and it makes a
difference and when you're facing a life
and death situation you start reading
the stuff that you guys are sending it
resonates even more so again thank you
and that's all I'm going to say for now
now you know you guys know what we do
over here I always say we highlight the
low lights these are the stories behind
the storytellers I'm very excited to
have this guest here today first time on
the Honeydew ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Neil Brandon welcome to the
Honeydew Neil Brennan
good to be here can't thank you enough I
should be here to even understand Brian
great to be here thank you uh before we
get into whatever we're going to talk
about plug and promote Everything Neil
Brennan please oh uh the big one that
I'm promo well I'm going on tour
um
it's generally if your city has a good
airport I'm coming you know what Amen to
the not so fast Charlotte
not coming
no we didn't have the chemistry
Asheville North Carolina look Asheville
had a shot Charlotte tried you twice we
don't got it
no Florida
you got a good airport you don't got any
Neil Brennan fans and no Ohio I could
have done Columbus just didn't
uh you know 20 cities that I'm
interested in that are interested in me
Mutual
approval and uh uh uh attraction
uh and so that's such a great art that
starts in March I think the first couple
cities or so I think they're still in
Nashville there's still some tickets in
L.A there's yeah go on the alberta.com
and I got a podcast based on my Netflix
special called blocks which started
streaming a couple months ago
uh where it's called blocks because it's
the things that make me feel like
something's the matter with me and
emotional mental blocks
um and so Jimmy Carr had the idea of
wanting to have people on and talk about
their blocks and um a few people in the
comments have compared it to this
podcast which you know I erased and
um but I've had Letterman Dave
Letterman's first fan I am watching
Letterman Sebastian Bobby Nikki Glazer
Taylor Thomas and Santino Ronnie Chang
uh and I'm doing Schultz and a bunch of
people next week so good good stuff good
people well you always take chances and
I like that I like the three mics like I
like the way you uh craft your craft I'm
a big fan of that part you know a lot of
people just get up there and do it which
is also great you know but but I love
the but I if I did that I would have
come in 50th
like I could be I could name a bunch of
people that are just better at
extemporaneously doing stand-ups so it's
like all right well I could come in I
don't know if it's 50th but I could
place
or I could do my own thing and win
because no one else is doing it that's
what I try to do I'm just going to stay
in my own lane over here and try to be
the best yep yeah
um so let's talk about it because I I
like I said I've been a fan of yours I
appreciate what you're doing over there
with the mug too it's nice what am I
doing putting it on put it on the coast
yeah I don't even know if it is now it's
nice
um I'm a fan and I know that uh going
back you were you were an atheist for a
while which which I am
um I grew up Catholic sure that's that
took care of that yep you know my
grandmothers were my grand hypocrisy
school yes very religious in the
Catholicism one of our aunts was a nun
great aunt when I say these are the
older ladies in the family but
um yeah it turned me off to you know
that'll do it it's all it took yeah like
honest to God and I know I say that not
jokingly but just listening to their
message and then watching what they do
it's a I don't understand how it's even
still a thing I had a friend that was
Muslim
and he used to make such a big deal
about not eating pork but he'd smoke
weed and he'd drink and finally I was
like hey
stop patting yourself on the back for
not eating pork because you do all this
other [__] and you makes the whole
religion look stupid and he was like
thank you apparent that's a good note
thanks for saying that but with
Catholics there's
so many rooms it's easy to put a pork
sandwich yeah exactly there's so many
goddamns I mean there's so many God it
you can't
people can take a little bit of
repression but it can't all be
repression and it's anything that you're
force-fed you're just gonna reject at a
certain point of course once you get the
option you're gonna [__] this I'm not
doing this [__] anymore because I didn't
choose it in the first place all these
good things that are actually some of
them are good for you uh you can't you
can't do them yeah you can't do them
yeah so let's talk about it because you
what you you had a DMT experience well
yeah I
[Music]
once a month
um it was weekly
if you do it once a month like oh yeah I
do comedy yeah once a lot of years of it
yeah oh man so yeah the guys I know that
went to Catholic School were high school
you know what I mean you went from wow I
got 13 years of education 12 of it
Catholic that's a lot yeah
um
so Catholic School altar boy Church mass
kneeling sit you know all that [__] oh
you were also involved in it too like
that you had to do alter boy stuff as
well yeah oh [__] yeah
um so yeah but you know when I I was a I
believed you know I don't you just want
to be good you wanna what will win this
how do I win this so you just go I
believe in it you don't know what you're
saying you don't even know what you're
talking about
and then
I was I'd say in my 20s I was like
spiritual
and then
on the and then I drove out here boy let
me ask you this what shifted when did
you finally let go of religion and shift
of spiritual and were you scared in my
20s it wasn't I wasn't I moved to New
York
and was involved in comedy I wasn't
going to go to mass you know what I mean
I wasn't wearing a cruise effect I
wasn't gonna just like what
um so I
do this slowly I then I read like The
Alchemist when you're 25 legally you
have to and uh and like then that was
sort of like I was kind of into that
were you scared were you scared to fully
let it go this belief that there's this
other thing I mean yeah but you know
what I found out later I was more scared
in retrospect of getting rid of my home
phone in favor of only a cell phone than
I was letting Catholicism
I had more anxiety about terrible home
phone
right away oh my God so I just gotta
like go to it's in my it's I just take
it out of my pocket
um I'll have to go to this wall what
will I do with my fingers what will I
wrap my fingers around
um so what will I throw when I lose a
bet yeah right right
um so
I don't want to snap something after a
medical diagnosis I want to [__] slam
it slam that [__] down uh so
I so yeah I was in there and then around
32 I drive out here
to direct a movie and I listened to
uh the Christopher Hitchens
book God Is Not Great I read that book
the book on tape is hilarious because
Christopher Richards has perfect smug
British dictionary it's [__]
outstanding I never listed I I just I'm
it was introduced to him from real time
yeah and um I remember him saying like
if I because he got sick and died I
think it was dementia maybe no throat
can't throw cancer but I remember him
Schultz did a joke about it that I hated
where he said like an atheist died of
Believers die every day of course they
did ding dong Jesus died yeah
he
um I remember him saying look if I start
preaching at the end about God and
everything I'm telling you I've lost my
mind or it's the drugs or whatever it's
not me having this come to Jesus so to
speak meeting and I found that
interesting that he planted that seed
before and I don't know I don't remember
if he ever got maybe that's what's
happening to me I wonder I wonder
um so drove out here listen to God Is
Not Great and listen to uh the game
uh something of a of a of a devilish
pair okay uh to listen to
um but
and then here's a [__] great like
flashback iron so like 10 maybe 10 years
later my dad's dying my dad's
went to Catholic school Mass raised all
his kids Catholic baptized weddings and
he mentioned he my dad had cancer and he
goes um
he goes uh oh I'm he goes I'm uh I'm not
beating I'm not fighting cancer it's
destroying me I'm not I'm not fi it's
like I'm getting pummeled and I go oh
that's like a Christopher Hitchens said
it had it like a bit like that and he
goes oh yeah I love I've read God it's
not great I loved
why would that blow your mind yeah it
was funny because he was going to mass
every day and reading God Is Not Great
and it's one of those like Cats in the
Cradle moments yeah uh that if I I just
but I still didn't like him
I'm sorry
sorry still didn't work
um so uh
so drove out here atheist and then was
an atheist from oh
seven
to uh 20
20 20. I mean this is pandemic yeah okay
so pandemic
um
friend sends me an article about
Ayahuasca if this is this is going to be
one of my Ayahuasca um podcast I want to
hear about it because I hear about it
and people yeah ever I I've talked about
on Rogan I've talked about it here and
there but like so but you know whatever
we all do but I want you to pull the
[__] La stank off of it you know what
I'm saying like you hear Ayahuasca a lot
and I hear and then yeah also like us
you know I know where we live and we're
full of [__] loonies but I I really
want to explore everything it's uh it's
it talk to me I here's the thing
Ayahuasca suffers from
it does suffer from it's like crypto
most of the people you heard about from
you heard about crypto from were
absolute douchebags yeah but a lot of
douchebags said I'm Rick James [__] a
lot of douchebags said Schwing a lot of
douchebags said my wife yeah I don't
mind that's what she said yeah that's
what she said I'm not blaming the office
Wayne's World uh oh yeah baby yeah I'm
not blaming Mike Myers I'm not moving
I'm not blaming I'm not blaming any of
these people for creating a thing that
people said because that doesn't make
any but it actually is like proof that
it's great that even douchebags
understood it
um
Ayahuasca so I get sent an article about
it from a friend and uh and I'm like all
right someone had told me about it five
years earlier great I text him he sent
me a number we arranged like a private
uh in my at my buddy's house hitters
right now and we do it okay so you're
not going to South America with a shaman
or any of these okay this guy is
technically a shaman I've come to call
him a rickety Shaman okay because he's
uh my buddy was like little Starbucks
see that guy he was white he was like a
white hippie and like hey well I'm doing
workout and oh hot you know just like ah
my experience that that time the first
time was uh great
um it was very pleasant it was I said
that it was like the you drink uh I a
half an ounce like little plastic shot
glass like rinse your mouth out like one
of those little glasses
um and then we all just laid there
Candlelight music but very nice music
and it was my experience was
I told somebody it was like the when you
go checking out when you go in your room
in a hotel and that video is on like
welcome to the Radisson it was that but
for like welcome to Ayahuasca and it was
like wide shots of the forest for like
an hour in my mind just like drone shots
of pine trees okay
then I cried probably for two hours
about groups of people about Humanity
which you wouldn't I wouldn't have
guessed beforehand
um
and like crying to the point where my
nostrils are so
they're they're so inflamed nothing's
getting in or out just like you can't
it's just CL it's a it's it's it's
bumper to bumper and you're in the same
room with the other two I'm in the same
room right here my friends five of my
friends yeah does that influence them uh
or is anything they're doing or feeling
influence you that you're hearing
whether they're laughing or crying
or you literally like locked in and
going through you can you're pretty your
hands are full okay you're not like
one I mean truthfully they offered a
second cup
I didn't take it one of my friends did
take the second cup
um and so we were all kind of wrapping
up she took the second cup because the
first cup didn't do anything and she
went
far off yeah to the point where
I believe she got a little possessed hmm
I've saw some possessions later we'll
get to that can we take one step
backwards and just tell us me especially
what actually is Ayahuasca it is what is
it different leaves and Roots it's a two
different be happy is one call if call
if one of the names and
um it's two different Leafs okay leaves
from and is it naturally grown like
shrooms or whatever it grows in the
Amazon but the crazy part is it grows
they grow far from each other the lore
of it is
a thousand years ago the plant itself
told indigenous people how to cook it
now
but look I know how that sounds good
look guys I'm coming into this sounds no
different I'm worth taking a rib out of
a man and making a woman to me it it uh
that now that's absurd now plants
talking that's that's right on time
um yeah so I get how insane that is
um having done it
I buy it 98 I hear you okay I appreciate
the two though thank you for that yeah
I'll leave it a little something
um uh uh the angel share as they called
in whiskey okay shout out to Whiskey
ginger guys whiskeygender.com Andrew
Santino
um the Okay so
me one of my friends I believe that
ceremony
vomited Purge they call it Purge his
mother's hatred of him up you purge up
things you purge up Notions you purge up
beliefs
Not Just Thoughts your physics some
people do have a physical reaction yeah
you think you're thinking it as you vom
it's it's it happened to me once and
it's pretty wild
um feel it moving through you
like does it feel like a toxic uh or a
poison I'm purged an apology to the
Earth
again okay just remember how cynical I
am just go watch tapes of me
from 2019. you got tapes go to your VHS
your betas
um the uh so yeah why like I that's what
I like about it is like I'm so known for
cynicism that it's like okay this got me
what was your apology
for uh what humans have done to the
Earth
just I apologize for it it was my
personal apology okay I've had friends
Purge up all kinds of stuff
um
so so one of my friends got possessed
the spirits were telling her to
masturbate in front of us like
pretty heavy [__] right
um one of the other Spirits told her
that me and my friend were trying to
assault her just like
she was possessed it wasn't based in any
kind of reality and we're all just
sitting there talking she's still in it
so that was the first time I did it and
it was like all right that was good
right how long does it last how long
that lasted three and a half hours hers
lasted about seven oh okay so that's
what I thought was more but this is well
because she had two cups the rest of us
just had one I see that's right so based
on that private I get in touch with
another friend who told me about it five
years earlier and I'm like hey I had a
good experience and she had tried to get
me to come to this circle uh out here
where it's a bunch of people and that do
it pretty regularly and it's very
ceremonial and so she puts me in touch
with them and I schedule a weekend to go
and I get there a couple of my friends
come with me and when do you remember
real sex on HBO of course you do yeah
remember where they do these field
pieces these videotape pieces of what
you just called videotape abuses
um of uh uh uh
uh where they go like we're interviewing
we're going to a swingers colony and it
was people unlike any you'd ever met in
life
this was like that when we me and my
friend walked in I go real sex take 12.
but the hippie Lilith Fair version
white flowing like kind of a cult
looking yeah I was gonna say that sounds
culty yeah it was super cold you have to
wear white because that's what they do
in Peru because Peru they do it in total
darkness so you wear white so people can
see you okay so they they using their
ceremonial uh practices they bring
whatever how I mean I feel like this is
relatively new for people here at least
in the states squares but how I've been
doing this two over two years just
[__] two years how long does this go
back though for real does this go back
to like the Incas and the Mayas and [__]
yeah when they talk about the medicine
man
that's who they're talking about they're
talking about they call it medicine
because that guy would do it and speak
to the spirit world right okay this
podcast is sponsored by better help when
you're at your best you can do great
things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you might feel
overwhelmed you might feel burnt out
therapists are trained to help you
figure out the cause of challenging
emotions and learn productive coping
skills so you can get closer to the best
version of you all right you know how
much I believe in therapy this is uh you
know this is a therapeutic podcast for a
lot of people I think it's important to
not just exercise your physical muscles
but your mind your emotions uh I think
therapy empowers you it helps you set
boundaries which is something I'm really
still learning how to do so there's
really to me there's no negative in
therapy at all so if you're thinking of
giving therapy a try then better help's
a great option it's convenient it's
flexible affordable and it's entirely
online so you just fill out this brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can always
switch therapists any time for no
additional charge all right so if you
want to live a more empowered life
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com honeydew today and you're
going to get 10 off your first month all
right that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash honeydew try it free
for 30 days that's enough time to try
and completely forget about a
subscription or a service before you
know it you're paying for a subscription
you don't use every single month and
with rocket money you can change that
with a few quick Taps rocket money
formerly known as true bill is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions it
monitors your spending and it helps you
lower your bills all in one place over
80 percent of people have subscriptions
they forget about like that streaming
service you bought just to watch the one
show you know or that free trial that
you never even used rocket money will
quickly and easily identify your
subscriptions for you so you can stop
paying for the ones you don't want you
simply find the subscription you don't
want you press cancel and boom rocket
money will cancel it for you no more
long hold times with customer service or
emailing back and forth over 3 million
people have used rocket money saving the
average person up to 720 a year and that
is a lot of money
um you know I personally
um do the same thing like I'll I'll sign
up for show time or something because I
want to watch the George and Tammy right
which I did and then I'm like man
other than boxing Showtime doesn't
really have anything I want right now
and then you forget right boom it's
another 12 bucks a month or whatever it
all adds up I know it so stop throwing
your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
honeydew that's rocketmoney.com honeydew
rocketmoney.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
first night I drink
uh and it doesn't I I have a cop nothing
happens have another cup nothing happens
and uh do this thing called hop a where
they blow
I call it jungle cocaine they blow uh
they stick a pipe in your nostril and
blow sacred Ash like sacred tobacco Ash
like actual tobacco like good tobacco
from the from the Amazon like not
processed [__] garbage [__] skull
no yeah
um and it's like blessed or something or
special in some way uh and they they go
like and it like you have to close your
throat and it's the worst thing I've
ever felt it felt like I was getting
waterboarded with sand oh it's like
rocks in your head yeah a lot of people
get it it's like a turbo button you get
it helps the
the
Ayahuasca like it's like uh you get like
10 times the Ayahuasca for 10 minutes
whatever it's like a it's like a SP it's
like the the mushroom in Mario basically
got it and um and uh nothing but old
references
um beta Max Mario video
um and um and
I drove my stick up to the ceremony yeah
yeah yeah
um and um
nothing worked Friday night even that no
I'm just now you're just annoyed I'm
nauseous and not only I'm annoyed people
are doing things like you may have a
block that you're and I'm like and I
literally was like you gotta stop I've
already done it it's worked for me and
then second night they changed the
formula a little bit
of amount they were giving me and like
bingo so you stayed overnight yeah
intentionally originally or because it
wasn't working yeah no that's how it
works but the other one was not an
overnight the first one it was a
one-nighter uh it's a one-nighter but
the cult where do you sleep at the cult
place on the floor in a in a basically a
finished garage
um it's couldn't that's the thing is
it's like this isn't glamorous it's
hippie-ish but also not uh there's like
I'm just in a sleeping bag next to some
dude and some lady it's not and they're
not
especially cool especially glamorous
especially like they're just really
regular like [__] regular people
and uh which is great because you just
you're all
kind of you all want the same thing
which is some sort of
yeah you just want a connection to the
it's on purpose or some guidance or
something it's interesting that
everybody's literally laying on a floor
and everyone's on the same level you
know no matter who you are you're
looking for answers and a connection and
hoping you can find it through this
process yeah yeah
um and and Theo's gone Roy Wood's gone
uh Nicole schreiber's gone like people
we know like Theo's gone more than once
I'd like to try it I'm always skeptic
and scared a little bit yeah I mean dude
there's always fear it's only going to
get scarier yeah this story FYI it gets
significantly worse
[Laughter]
um so
and second night I'm like I I I just hit
it hit me and I was [__] ecstatic
like just like
beaming now can I ask you I ask a lot
I'm so curious is it is it a familiar
feeling like you felt before is it
different better is it what are you
feeling now it is are you like there it
is maybe the longest sustained period of
Joy I've ever felt wow okay
hour and a half two hours of bliss three
hours of bliss wow and then
same night I believe
two hours of crying over friendship to
the point where I thought when I turned
my phone on the friend was gonna be dead
like that's the level of just that low
but it wasn't
that was also nice do you know what I
mean yeah like it was beautiful it was
like it connected
friendship so
so at a certain point they're in this
ceremony that I do it in the circle I do
it in
um
there's all there's two different
religious uh
um
sort of
uh
like he's pulling from two different
religious ceremonies one's called
umbanda which is a
uh afro-caribbean religion from like 8
000 years ago or something wow and and
uh a number yeah I believe it's around 8
000. and another one called Santo dime
where again the leaves are gonna speak
a hundred years ago a guy is in Brazil
and he's he's like a rubber Trapper and
uh kind of a cool thing about it that's
kind of cool and by the way the guys
look like is like six nine and looks
like he's friends with Bill Russell
that's the only way I can explain it
um let me show you his picture so you
know what I'm talking about
um
the uh I think there's a Bill Russell
doc getting ready to come out on Netflix
so if you ever read his book great
this is the guy
oh holy [__] six nine yeah six nine
yeah
and this is from like 19. that's also a
face it looks like it's scenes yeah he
would drink gallons of so anyway I don't
even know if he did Iowa two he's
walking in the forest and two like we'll
call him wood nymphs appear to him and
say hey
you gotta spread the word about
Ayahuasca and he's like how and they
could make a religion he goes It's
Brazil it's like everything's Catholic
and they go make it look Catholic
so
this it's called Santo Dame and they
have like crucifixes but with two beams
it looks like the Marx brothers were
like the cops are coming we gotta make a
religion it's like a star of David's
sort of it's so goddamn funny from like
a comedy writing board would you look at
it yeah you're like oh like they'll
never suspect
so and the music's super cool whatever
so in the ceremony we do the some Santo
Dame dances there's some
again dude there's a thing called the
celestial Court
they open up the room to Spirits long
story short I open my eyes in the middle
of this
and I go
oh I'm in the presence of God right now
that's when it hits you yep like I can't
explain it any other way I am in the
presence of God
before the faces melt okay I remember
when they opened the ark and they yeah
beautiful mode
the only dialogue is it's beautiful
that's all someone says it was like that
and no faces melt so
I was just like all right this is the
only this is the first this is what they
said church was was but again are you
seeing feeling it okay I'm like I'm
pretty like you're present with eyes
open you're feeling everything yes I'm
president of the eyes open but it's like
they're a little watery like I had a
Glock but but I'm still conscious I'm
still Blissful I'm still probably
thinking about my friend like I'm in
this emotional thing and again I go
ahead and poke holes in it I it's fine
it's not gonna change my experience
what's your experience anyway the person
next to you could have a completely
different one in the same room on the
same drug yes
um
and a weird thing like my friend came
and she was like rolling her eyes the
whole time like this is so stupid this
is so corny and everyone does a share
after each ceremony and one of the
people shared that she's like I don't
know I had these visions of like
barbed wire and like
concentration camp and my friend starts
crying she'd had the same vision the
skeptical friend yeah oh that's what
made it change yeah so she was like oh
and like a third woman also just like
weird [__] that you can't
I have a crazy story that I don't want
to forget but I want to I don't want to
tell it yet okay
so I'm gonna you I'm gonna I'm gonna
preview it
um so anyhow
I'm like all right I'm in the presence
of God
I don't know how I now not only do I
believe it I'm like my ex I'm
experiencing it it wasn't like oh there
was no light there was just like this is
just
standing More Than A Feeling yeah yeah
more like they had to be powerful for
you to go from all this Catholic School
of the 13 year or 12 years to overcome
like the [__] you of that like never
again and then be like oh if this had
happened I never leave all of that was
just
like a game of telephone based that's
what I think now based on my experience
that's a game of telephone
there is a central creation Force
but that's about the only thing that's
right to me now having said that in this
circle in the celestial Court
um there's an altar and it's got the
fake crucifix it's got the phony
crucifix it's got a Buddha it's got
Jesus it's got Virgin Mary and it's got
Archangel Michael again something that I
barely remember from Catholic school but
like whatever he's big in this
um
and there's Gods called Ori Shahs and
um they all have different names and
they represent the Sea and the like just
kind of greekish
for lack better word uh Kendrick Lamar
references them not this record but the
record before okay uh
uh what's the name I don't I can't
remember the name of it
um but it sounds like Metatron that's
one of the or the Ori shouts that he
references in his whatever it's not
um a Transformers reference
um so I know what you're thinking and
it's not it's not a Transformers it's a
it's an umbanda uh deity that I have no
information on other than like I know
that they exist and that's all I know
and this this you're drinking a liquid
so are they like boiling it is it like a
tea they boil it at some point up the
stream by the time it's not hot like by
the time it gets to like people in
America to drink it's not legal so they
have to like transport it in weird ways
um so so that's my first weekend and
wait let's go back yeah I don't want to
just gloss over that you're feeling good
more you're feeling God though you're
believing in it now for the first time
in quite a while so yeah like genuinely
like the way you go
I'm in love and then you're actually in
love you're like oh this is in love that
other thing was just some fake [__] to
get a girl to [__] me all right so are
you just gonna get God to bug me are you
happy with it are you scared of it like
where are you at this point I'm like I
literally was like I'm gonna well the
first night I drank it I stood up and
the first night with all my friends at
the other but I was like I'm gonna be a
[__] Zealot for this like I literally
an hour and I was like this is insane
because it was mushrooms
mushrooms you'll have like
five funny thoughts in a minute right
like this was like
wow
and you're like I was laughing like why
I literally said wow I was like this is
wild then what's happening
Okay so
I've done this circle right with I did
it with the people in the sort of
ceremony
um now you're not gonna believe this but
some of the people in the circle had
some uh had some ideas about covet
and maybe someone had some conspiracy
theories and maybe people weren't
wearing masks
in the fall of 2020 and maybe we left
Sunday and on Tuesday someone pested
positive and I was like guys
could we then could we test
they were kind of like no
so
um I then went back to the original
rickety Shaman okay for a private with a
one-on-one uh me Ian Edwards and my
friend Catherine who had the the uh
barbed wire
um and that's where I drank well I don't
you don't know the story so we're just
doing it and again nothing's working for
me
Catherine's it's hitting her and it's
hitting Ian nothing's working for me and
I'm like
so I've had like three cups I'm like
should I have like a fourth and the
guy's like let me see your pupils he's
like okay
fourth and uh
Catherine had been having a hard time
she was just like
eyes closed like
oh and she literally was like God this
is [__] taking a long time she was
just like not in good shape
and Ian was doing great and my fourth
cup
it's the old it's the oldest drugstore
in the world like [__] this doesn't
work let me get more whoopsie and it was
one of the great whoopsies
of my life
I because this is your third time ever
anyway right at this fourth Tech the
fourth night okay
um
and
it hits me I start seeing like watery my
eyes are water water as [__]
it's like
it's kind of churchy in that you know
how like a um scrim will come in
confession there's like a scrim it was
as if there was a scrim but of like
rattlesnake skin Oh [__] right and I'm
getting what I then Purge
my apology for climate change
and then
I my something that my other my good
Shaman refers to as brain dissolution
happens mind dissolution where I think
the word what and my brain goes
and I'm like how long does that last
a couple hours hours dude you can't shut
it off no you're just and I'm literally
going I'm gonna be a [__] drug
casualty to the point where I I mean it
was so you're stuck in that for two
hours and she and I was like to the
point where I was so lost that I was
going
I this is how I knew I should have known
that I was in there because I kept
thinking if you're just joining us what
is anything
you're saying I'm thinking that thing
like in the tone of if you're just
joining us I'm like what is anything
what is any I didn't know it's a great
question it's a great question it is it
really is
um now okay so I'm I'm in ut world what
is anything then I get thrust to outer
space
by myself
is it silent then yeah well it couldn't
be quieter okay so the what's have
stopped in outer space uh I'm just
really overloaded and are you like out
there floating among by myself not in a
ship or anything you're just out there
by myself and
I and the universe died
so what happens if you're in outer space
Rivers black holes
uh uh electricity
human Souls
aliens I mean all of it
top to bottom nebula Galaxy in this [__]
or feeling it I'm feeling it I'm feeling
like I get that we're shutting it down
and I'm by myself and I started
breathing
hmm
it's like a yoga breathing
called samadhi breathing
um and I didn't know how long I did it
Ian told me recently I did it for
several hours hours and the reason I did
it was as a beacon in space to help
someone find you yep
if someone got within three feet of me
they could have heard me yeah
I love it I did it you were conscious
enough to send us
so well yeah I'm not going out like with
nothing I'm not just gonna go out I'm
gonna send a beacon up
um and
so that ends right I can show you a
photo of the next morning
because I'm dude I was on my back
and
uh and I got mad at the shaman because I
was like dude I was not
I was in really bad shape like and he's
like well as a former human with as a
former uh EMT
um I can tell you that uh you were never
in danger which is like I don't know if
you can tell me that
sire
um it's uh it's so but you'll see how I
vomited and it's not a great way to
vomit you'll see it on my shirt
um so while you were laying there you
also when you've actually Purge you
threw up on yourself yeah you did yeah
and uh I don't know if you I'll send you
can post this
what the f
I'm just trying to imagine how the [__]
you did I don't know either
it looks like a [__] rule yes send
that to us yeah for real that is uh it's
a [__] interesting pattern to [__]
yeah
so and not not an insubstantial amount
that's a lot about yeah but not to be
just yeah two streams yeah
um so those nostrils was it through your
nose no it was Purge that's what purge
looks like anyhow
so I'm that's the next morning I like
just kind of woke up and
Ian said I knew you were going to be
okay I just knew you were gonna be okay
I can't explain I just knew like
whatever's going on he's gonna be okay I
was [__]
terrified for three days
in the world after that yeah like I've
never thought I had PTSD before I was
like oh I think this is what PTSD is
where I'm just scared I thought glass
was kind of I was gonna say what are you
what are your fears uh falling down
steps like kind of like the omen [__] or
like
scary movie [__] but irrational things
nothing you had ever done before or no
just like I'm just now I'm worried about
bad things happening to me okay
um but like I slept with the lights on
no idea
um but
a few days into it I either thought I
had to go off antidepressants to do it
to to drink I honestly you can't be on
ssris because it'll you can get
serotonin syndrome because it released a
lot of Serotonin whatever whatever and
either thought
like my so my the floorboards of my mood
were sort of gushy after when I quit
doing uh ssris like they I was like I
could feel that like I could go into a
pretty significant depression like they
were the floor was there but it was like
ah it's well not the most reliable I
hear you and after the that bad night
higher
firm polished
without the meds yeah and I was like oh
I think I'm not gonna be depressed
anymore
so that was great right
but again pretty steep way to get there
but kind of like I like
like [__] did a thing to my brain
that changed my brain it's crazy enough
out there we shouldn't send your world
spinning all right you gotta ditch the
paranoia and take a toke of something
low dose and highly enjoyable dag grass
brings back the Mellow joints of
yesteryears to keep your soul light and
your head right that grass is legal it's
organic smokable hemp that relaxes your
body and Mellows your mind they're 100
organic pre-rolled joints as I always
tell you are my favorite and flour are
very low in THC and they're high in CBD
so you can enjoy the effects of CBD
while keeping a clear head and if you're
not looking to toke that grass also
offers the finest tinctures and gummies
on the market all the Mellow goodness no
smoke required all that grass products
are federally legal for ages 18 and over
and they ship right to your door
anywhere in the U.S so whether you're
looking for a new Buzz or a chill way to
enjoy an old favorite dad grass will
leave you in your fork mood look I know
a lot of my friends they don't like the
high potent stuff out there but they
still want to enjoy
um CBD and THC and I always recommend
dad grass I'm recommending it to you if
if it's too powerful for you or if it
causes paranoia I get it all our systems
are different but I'm telling you Dad
grass is a very good low-dose CBD smoke
all right and right now that grass is
offering my list there's 20 off your
first order when you go to daggrass.com
honeydew go to daggrass.com honeydew for
20 off your first order that's
dadgrass.com honeydew this time of year
everyone's talking about making big
changes which is all well and good but
sometimes they're a little unrealistic
and I've actually found that the
smallest changes to your routine can
make the biggest impact in the same way
you don't have to break the bank to make
a big deal purchase even the smallest
things can be a part of a big change if
it's something you use every day like my
raycons raycon is premium audio at the
perfect price point so you can build
great habits without breaking the bank
all right now
I'm telling you when I'm on tour raycons
Kirsten's constantly using array cons
I'm not allowed to say certain names on
here but I'll just tell you this we like
them better than anybody else's airpods
out there she uses them at the gym I was
using them at the gym I can't tell you
how much I used them while I was in the
hospital all right and not only are they
water and sweat resistant but the tap
functions make it easy to flip through
music and adjust the volume without even
needing to pull your phone out so
whether you're looking for a pair of
everyday earbuds low latency gaming
headphones or a speaker with a battery
that will last all night at your next
party raycon's got you covered raycon
started half the price of other premium
audio Brands so you don't even have to
choose between products you can get one
of each or a pair to spare and still pay
less than you would with some of the
other guys even if you know you'll love
your raycons as much as I do raycon
wants to make sure you feel great about
your purchase they offer buy now pay
later options and every purchase has an
easy and free return guarantee I'm
telling you it's worth it alright so if
you're ready to buy is something small
with a big impact go to byraycon.com
honeydew today to get 15 off your raycon
order that's byracon.com
honeydew to score 15 off by
raycon.com slash honeydew nah let's get
back to the do
okay so now
I didn't hold it against Ayahuasca that
night I held against the rickety
shopping
fair enough and
you also did four shots yeah yeah so I
was basically like a bachelorette and uh
yeah like I'm not blaming the man I mean
so
[Laughter]
so uh
I'm like the guy who's wanted to sue
Vegas yes so
so a couple days later I so I'm like I
so I go to more ceremonies with like the
you know I get vaxed early
um like wait in line overnight and all
that [__] so I get waxed mostly so I
could do more I lost and uh because it's
not like a ton going on and uh and get
backs go to another ceremony next
several ceremonies were
real tough because in what way
because I had this bad experience so now
I'm like are you my mental battling
yourself yeah one point my heart started
racing really fast
uh maybe the same ceremony
I heard a tiger in the room oh dude
like acoustically
there's a tiger in the room yeah no
thank you and a baby tiger comes around
the um Altar and it's the only time in
my life I went like in my life girls
will do it twice a week
um knocking a girl's bathroom door
without telling her and she's gonna I
that's the only time baby tiger like
[__] not doing good
but I also felt in one of those
ceremonies I always felt like my I had
like a heaviness like there was like
lead on like I had a lead helmet on my
head like just like having this to my
spirit and in one of those ceremonies I
just felt
like pressure like air pressure
take it off
but also next ceremony I thought the
Rapture came thought it was the Rapture
I'm like this is it this is the rapture
do all kinds of things each one yes it's
not consistent at in any way for you no
and but you're not so nervous about it
that you're like all right [__] this you
still going I met somebody said why are
you doing this I was like I met God yeah
I what else am I gonna do see that
sounds also just same way like junky
[__] mentality man put that heroin
man I met [__] God but it's not like
no I'm getting my dick sucked but it's
not that it's literally like dude so is
that what you're looking for every time
you go back yeah well you're coming even
I mean you're communing with
um
a a palpable higher power not imaginary
it's like not the universe because you
saw the universe die so it's bigger than
the Universe I mean it came back so is
it love they didn't they didn't it did
they didn't kill the universe yeah all
right they didn't go yeah he ducked the
universe
um the uh no you're just experienced
you're like you feel connected to all
living beings ever maybe and uh let's go
back to how Neil feel for just a moment
thank you very much how what are you
searching out now that you've got these
three four under your belt are you going
for more answers well now I'm looking
for like and now I'm also seeing it as
like a top off for depression for like
staving off depression because I can't
take SSRI or I stop taking ssris and
you're my one impression was good during
that time as well yeah it was good but I
didn't want to not do Aya for three
months and it dips you know what I mean
so I was doing that but really hard like
tigers rapture
uh
uh you know just CR just rough [__] and
what are your gaps in between days
yeah maybe once a month okay
um so I maybe go another weekend that's
like three nights I mean three weeks is
a long time to be off of meds and still
feel okay from one session in Ayahuasca
yeah that is impressive yeah so but it
was sometimes it was two months probably
like it was you know it was a bunch
um I really gave up on that coaster huh
um so uh so and then around the
maybe lifetime my eighth ceremony
um I I'm kind of out of the PTSD Zone
and they do the celestial court or the
Angelic Court as it's known they
literally play calling all Angels you
wanna you can't they play the song
Calling All angels for to open the
celestial court it's nauseated
um as a snob as a cultural snob he's
like you can't play it's a little on the
nose no but it works because uh so
anyway I'm
in ceremony and I start
two three hours in
start doing this
I'm not really controlling it it's just
like but you're aware of it yeah
and uh for like
an hour and a half two hours
three hours what
my body's just doing this right just
lightly seizing
[__] it's just rocking I don't know yeah
and
a woman walks past named Lucia I sound
like a goofball but I what it doesn't
mean he still did all the [__] I did yes
I still got Netflix but I got TV shows
uh sorry sorry yeah sorry
um uh
uh and a woman walks past named Lucia
dancing there's really great music and
it's it hits you nice and
she's like Brazilian anyways she's a
good dancer and and I do like the joke
thing by the way I can write jokes on it
I've written jokes that worked on you
have yes okay funny mean tags you're
also mentally clear yeah for sure yeah
you're not like you're I'm mostly there
um and Lucia walks past dancing and I
Joe and I'm rocking and I jokingly think
yeah when he's gonna start dancing like
Lucia like you know what I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna get in shape
it's like that tone like I'm gonna start
dancing like Lucia I think that and
immediately
I start doing what she was doing and I'm
not in control of it you got up and down
I didn't get up at that point I just
myself
and uh is she like looking at you is
like they're an energy connection but
like I picked it up
that's wild you're reading some physical
cues from somebody else instead of
verbal and then that whole night I was
then I got up and was and I'm doing [__]
that I'm not in control there's Angels
in the Outfield I mean you don't strike
me as a dancer I don't strike you as a
dancer but but did you nail it bet
against me
what would you have put your money
before then no I can dance I'm [__]
comics for a [__] it's all rhythm
um and uh and
pretty much every time I've done
Ayahuasca since I or mushrooms or I did
uh MDMA recently and
I go into this [__] weird
spasm they're called like I think
they're called uh
mudras it's in it's in uh Indian uh it's
in another uh [__] Buddha and I put
his mug whatever but it seems like a
comfort level it's not uncomfortable
it's just weird it's weird but I'm not
like what's going on I'm just like I
just let my mind go blank and my body
just does [__]
and um so that was
uh that's sort of the story until
July 2021 okay
um and
and uh and then I started going
then I went to New York to do what
became the blocks Netflix thing and so
I'm in New York I don't have a circle to
do it there
someone tells me about
uh they have access to bufo
5meo DMT the one that you smoke like DMT
now the active ingredient in Ayahuasca
is DMT is that right yeah but it's like
in tea so you just your body metabolizes
it way slower you smoke it it's crap
right right
now can I ask you because I I'm
I think a lot of people are surprised I
don't really do I'm weed in shrooms like
I don't I'm not none of these pills like
even when I was in the hospital they
would mention these pills and I'm like
what and they would get annoyed with me
almost that I didn't know this you know
yeah it's awesome and I'm like I don't
know I don't do these things I don't
know I hate those things DM let me show
you a picture of little Wayne nothing
[Music]
DMT is it not a chemical your body
releases as it's apparently um the
chemical your body release when you die
they can't prove that I don't believe
but they they suspect that that's what
happens so that's what we're talking
about I'm not far off all right okay but
it this is is this also something that's
natural to uh uh it's in toad uh Venom
or something uh Sonoran toad got it they
scrape the one where the the animals
lick its back and start tripping and
basically it's like yes it's like in
that family
they put it they literally milk them
onto glass it dries then you play it
Flakes and you smoke that but it's the
active ingredient in Ayahuasca is in DMT
but this is pure Vibe Meo ain't nothing
there but DMT go ahead smoke it always
struck me as too severe I was like ah it
sounds severe yeah I'd heard Michael
Pollan talk about a Rogan show and I was
like that seems too how much are we
talking when we're talking a little bit
you're talking about drops salt like a a
bunch of like nothing nothing
um
but I get like hey you want to do it do
you have an opening tomorrow night if
you want to go okay so this is also
regulated in the sense that there's
someone that'll guide you for this yeah
you're so far gone
people smoke it in Vapes apparently
which is it's not bufo it's not five Meo
it's like
a different type of DMT I've seen people
do it they seem okay I would when I tell
you the story you'll never do it
so uh I go to the this is November 1st
22. now
2021 November 1st 2021
I go uh at eight o'clock to a hotel room
New York
and I
I basically sit there it's a guy who's
like sort of in charge uh not even a
shamish just like it's great it's
wonderful I do it
you you smoke you go
and you literally fall back like it's
and I went to what Michael Pollan
described on Rogan's show as going to a
place
before the Big Bang
okay
that's how far back this feels
I my experience of it was I'm basically
an amoeba I'm I don't know Direction I
don't know breathing I don't know I know
exactly nothing
and I must have been in there because
I'm panicking because you don't know
it's like what am I'm like it was like
it felt like the first moment of
consciousness wow [__] any Consciousness
hold on a second yeah
I mean that's interesting because our
first Moments Of Consciousness we don't
even remember yeah exactly and now you
have a feeling of that
yeah but that's all you have nothing
else makes sense yeah I I mean dude you
just know you're present I'm I am uh
awake I'm on I've been switched on yeah
yeah whatever I am has been switched on
and
I remember
feeling like I formed a synapse
like
and I also remember hearing the term or
I don't know where
God's not here yet yet yeah like
right does that mean he's coming in 10
minutes or like you're so new to
everything right yeah yeah so this is
[__] I'm like this is a completely
different experience like I'm not a per
I don't even know what a person is yeah
yeah I don't know anything
and then slowly but surely over the next
30 minutes
your Consciousness comes in comes back
and but they're feeling pretty cool
it felt like I was rebuilding myself
building okay and I'm not discovering
that I have this part and stuff hey was
like I when I say rebuilding it was more
like I because I'd have a petty thought
I'd be like no we're not doing that
anymore
and I was beaming I was like because
it's crazy yeah it's crazy what's
happening you're like laying and you're
going like I don't want to be that and
you feel really
uh
uh connect like it just feels like a
different
Consciousness or a different experience
of
sentience or life or whatever so
I inhale at nine I'm walking home I
inhaled at eight I'm walking home at
nine really yeah
the guy offered me a second hit I was
like no
I was like well that's people do another
one
so
how do you feel on the welcome yeah what
do you think I feel like clean
you ever do LSD no sure
there's a there's like a
feeling after LSD where you're like
oh your your brain feels pretty clean I
felt my brain felt pretty clean
um this is on November 1st I believe
it's a Monday
um
and
so I do my show that week and I still
feel like myself so wait you shot the
special no I'm just doing it last work I
was gonna say doing it in like a theater
I felt like myself
and Saturday night the sixth or seventh
or whatever uh Ryan Hamilton comes
and it was really fun to do because I
could hear him laughing and it's like
doing an hour and I can hear Hamilton
what he's laughing at and it was like
crowded and it was great we're walking
home and I'm like yeah man I'm not an
atheist anymore and he grew up uh Mormon
so I'm like kidney and he's like I might
not believe
um and we're walking home and as I'm
telling about DMT and and and
ayahuasca
can feel myself like drifting a little
bit
into that white void DMT world and I'm
like
this is weird but I'm like yeah talking
dog
I go upstairs
to my apartment that I'm staying in and
I'm I watch the uh
Linda Ronstadt documentary on HBO plus
sold 80 million records no she had no
idea no idea 80 million right I wouldn't
have guessed I know I know that's what
I'm saying what was so great about the
documents for the internet yeah man tube
because she sold them on vinyl and a
track and like she saw them on different
formats yeah and
um and
I'm like drifting into this DMT world
I'm like I gotta get to sleep because I
this is getting weird where I'm like
halfway between
alive and that
and you feel like you could slip into
that side if you let yourself go
yeah and
I wake up the next day
still drifting
and now I'm like it's worse
I go on a coffee date with a woman and
at one point like
all I can say is like my Consciousness
is disintegrating
I'm like talk imagine talking to me and
like this is becoming white static
I think I would describe it as pre
psychotic damn okay I believe I again
never been psychotic but my friend of
mine helped me and she'd been psychotic
at one point she was explaining like oh
okay like so and she said I seemed I was
just scared I was like
I I I don't know what she's like you
just seem really preoccupied because it
was like right here this [__]
something
and
I had the thought on that was Sunday
then Monday I was like this is notice
the worst day of my life this is the
worst day of a life
any life
and I also thought I wouldn't wish this
on Adolf Hitler
it's an actual actual thought
s other actual thought it would dude it
was so disorienting I was like how many
days after now uh four or five a full
week yeah there at 70 70 of people that
smoke DMT have a reactivation
like a flashback type thing most of them
are short
mine was not short what's considered
short a couple of hours yeah and it's
minutes yeah you got days going on now
uh
uh next day I thought
I should I don't I think I'll probably
have to kill myself if this keeps up you
really thought that yeah but the reason
I didn't was because I knew I'd be going
into more of it
kill yourself and then you're just
living in that [__] yeah so dying or
whatever yes and existing so I just like
didn't I just like and it wasn't suicide
you know what I mean it wasn't despair
it wasn't
depression it was disorientation
next day I was like five I was half of a
percent better and I got like half a
percent better for
I guess that would be uh
not even kidding six months
what that long Neil yeah
I every day considering these things no
it got better not suicide so to speak
but like I got better that was no early
November December 20th I go to the
dentist I do laughing gas
back wow white world like and I'm like I
literally was like hey can we stop real
quick
and uh I kind of had to get back in line
start back up around the same time I get
on a I'm on a plane falling asleep
turbulence and my first thought is like
what am I
like I'm it's pretty and I'm doing my
show
I'm walking on the steps to the stage
going like what is this I know how to do
this show but I don't even know to throw
your timing or anything off really not
really what okay so this is six months
yeah are you doing Ayahuasca during this
at all now are you just staying off of
everything give it a rest I just wanted
to make sure okay all right we're gonna
give that a rest
um and uh and I'm just trying to get
like normal again have you talked to
doctors or are you just shot I was
convinced I still I think I'm right I
knew I couldn't really talk to a
therapist about this I was so far
I mean unless they've literally gone
through this yeah there are like
grounding exercises you can do there are
things you can do but I was so far out
I was I told a friend of mine like I was
past the Sun
damn I was that thought but but I'm
still drinking and I'm not Dr like I'm
still I you probably saw me I'm sure it
didn't I didn't well I've watched your
special you were right doing during that
you did this I or you were going through
this yeah no I shot the special this
year so I SP I basically shot the
special uh eight months later eight
months so this lasted six yeah so there
was a window yeah forever it was dude I
couldn't watch sunsets I couldn't watch
the Apple TV screensaver those like
Crystal 4K shots would start to send you
in the I knew
all right so we're all we all put
blinders on I'm just like I'm gonna get
to Santa Monica do my pocket or whatever
whatever
and then someone goes isn't it crazy
like that that ocean is the oceans 500
000 years old and you go yeah it's crazy
man yeah nothing happens
I knew
how I understood amount I can't explain
it like the blinders were off
and I at some point I experienced I
think in the first couple days I
experienced
uh interacting with the central creation
force of the universe oh my God and
you're over there to the main Hub but it
wasn't a person it was like uh whatever
it is it was like a raw uh like black
Matt
uh
Rock for lack of a better word and there
was another person there
and I was like yeah and I was like again
I don't know when I dreamed I don't know
what but I was like this is
God and they were like yeah and then
both of our brains got like Zapped
and I was like
what are you what am I
like what what is it what is anything
and uh
I'm gonna chill because it's it was
really hard and
um and
so I slowly recovered and again you
wouldn't have known you wouldn't I'm
driving to normal [__] doing spots and
by the way I'm crushing like I'm doing
great so
the weird thing is
um I'm that thing that happened with the
my mind is now higher and firmer than it
was even after that like I'm never gonna
be depressed like not even did you go
back to meds no you're off your
depression man yeah really yeah and you
feel good yeah do you regret DMT
because I know this is probably an
interesting question I don't that's the
thing I if like given this like do I do
it in time machine do I do it again I
don't think I do you don't
now having said that
I'm better in every single way and
that's where I wanted to really go was
like do you feel the education you got
from the DMT uh as far as you know how
it's influenced you do you think I was
worse
in my body you are my body is different
what are you doing differently are you
working out more are you
um I was gonna say is there any dietary
[__] that comes with it I want you to do
a podcast where there's a secret word
that you have to say and it's like a
podcast where keto's Gonna Get You know
and then all right we can go confetti
Falls
um the I just am my view is better my I
I uh you eat fast food do you feel it
differently you know what I mean are you
more in touch with your body now like
more like that it's more
my understanding of life is different in
that it's I now believe
that
I am a spirit
that existed before 1973
and I'm in this body
uh I was born in 1990.
um okay
um uh that I'm in this body
temporarily yeah and when I die I'm
going back to that white world but I'm
gonna do we come out understand it like
I'm not gonna it's not gonna terrify me
right that's what I think that again I
hear you but let me ask you nothing not
me either I know nothing but I do
believe what you believe I believe we're
just meat sacks yeah right now until I'm
trying to figure out the best way to be
and I don't understand why me but like I
one of my big questions when I do these
ceremonies like why is my life the way
it is
the good and the bad
and I don't think I'll ever it's a
[__] egotistical thing
what but what's going on you know but
it's hard not to ask sure and now you
say have you done Ayahuasca since at all
or you didn't do it for
uh year
I did it
uh 11 months after the DMT and how was
that it was great it was yeah and I had
uh things happen that had never happened
before on island Ayahuasca yeah I think
that was DMT related those things
I don't know I mean are you gonna do DMT
again I wouldn't do DMT if you offered
me one billion with a B dollar oh wow
billion Neil you could feed a lot of
people don't care they gotta start I'm
not doing that again that's never going
to happen again yeah like not wow it's
not going it's I cannot do it again but
Ayahuasca Ayahuasca literally done again
but only once since or since but I made
schedule-wise I may do it like in April
or May like okay I'm not I'm very
interested about the meds though because
I don't wanna I'm not telling none of us
are telling anyone to get off their meds
I'm just not interested for you really
no okay but no I mean that's helping the
stuff I did prior to I did TMS
transcribing simulation that helped me
meds helped me uh EMDR help me yeah
so I can't sit here and say don't do
don't do this anything they all help me
the the but DMT
help me I mean all those things helped
about 15 and then DMT was like we'll
take it from here 85 we got it and it
was like it was
uh
you've heard the story it's like
it scares the [__] out it's scarier than
I'll never do it now it's so much again
I did five Meo DMT and poofo so many
don't care I don't know street name bufo
uh
it's it's you're and I talked to Rogan
about this they're legalizing all these
things and it's like you know hey just
so you know this is some Pandora's Box
like a [__] like yeah and cool
and it's like I've seen people get
possessed I was well Salvia is legal and
people think Salvia is you know because
it's not illegal it's a practice version
of weed and it is crazy oh I've had a
guest come on that lived in a parallel
universe for eight years and started to
believe that that was his real [__]
it was eight Callen Earth calendar years
are they so at the end of it it was 60
or excuse me one minute 60 seconds and
it was eight calendar years in that
[__] world and he counted it what did
he get done he had a job at a Tyler uh
Tyler he moved to Tyler Texas he had a
Volkswagen Bug he originally had a
family with children and cried every
night and then so he was the guy at the
grocery store telling everyone I don't
belong here I have a family and he
became that guy that they thought was
mentally challenged and you know crazy
and everything until he finally had to
tell people the grocery store I now know
that my father mother and sister were
killed in a car crash and they were like
there's the guy we know and love there
he is there but by the way that wasn't
the guy at all and then he woke up
um and one minute one minute later but
he had lived eight [__] painstaking
years in this alternate universe missing
his kids and his wife and kids or he
said he couldn't stop hugging him
they're like Dad you know he's been
going for a minute to them or not and
then it starts to make you think about
life and time and what time really even
[__] I mean you spend 60 minutes but
it's eight years there and then you
think all right well that's where 10
minutes of Di
it's a lifetime I believe anything now
me too that shifted me [__] crystals
[__] it yep go get out the Sedona and
charge them up let's go girl I'm worse
crystals
um yeah like I don't
know dude
all the [__]
you don't think I got some selenite in
my house I don't even know what to do
with it
um and uh so the story I was gonna that
I was like I'll tell you the story later
this is just crazy
this on Reddit someone sent me this
the question was what's the craziest
thing I was because ever told you to do
Ayahuasca presents as a woman is that
right yeah Okay and like speaks to you
um it hasn't happened to me but it
happens to lots of people
uh she will speak to you
um and
the someone wrote
she told us to watch Neil Brennan's
Netflix special
okay
I someone sends me this I go so I DM the
kid I go
what is what do you mean
any ropeak did it happen to you too it
happened to three of us
three different people in ayahuasca
ceremony were told to watch
my comedy
I DM the kid again he's he hasn't
responded probably freaking the [__] out
on me putting real life on that now too
it's really Neil Brennan messaging me I
didn't say who I was I said it was like
my he's dating me I had some very
credible lie
um trust me
um but uh [__] like that happens all the
time and it's still things pop up like
that too you find in that yeah and so
Ayahuasca yes DMT [__] yeah that would
be my position
mushrooms yes MDMA yes for me do you
have my body but you don't smoke weed do
you do you no don't like it does nothing
for me
um so
so yeah but I'm that I'm improved in
every way yeah audiences like me more
people are like are you whatever like
I'm lighter I'm just like I feel it yeah
I other people feel it I feel it but
then other people say it before I say
it's undeniable when a bunch of
different people start coming up and all
saying the same thing you know like I
never thought I had an accent until I
moved here and it's undeniable that I
have an accent not you know it's not
Baltimore no not there statistically
though bro yeah yeah this has been a
[__] fantastic episode it's answered
a lot of questions I've had both about
DMT in Ayahuasca it's also like I said
you pulled the stank off of it because
you hear all these people like let's go
do I and I'm like also they're not doing
it in any way like you did with someone
who's there you know they're just
[__] out there they're doing it with
they're doing people that don't speak
English that don't have ceremony that
just go drink it and lay their their
experiencing things that they don't
understand
around people that aren't equipped to do
and the last time I did it
it's [__] insane dude like last time
I did it it's like hitting me hard right
like really hard and
a the shaman sent over a woman that does
um uh it's the tobacco thing that
mapacho it's called that's the tobacco
in Brazil it's called mapacho that was
lifting up your nose yeah but this is
that's like ash I think it's whatever
but she
smokes a pipe and then blows into your
Crown chakra your net and like I was
[__] up and I got like
cleared really yeah in six minutes and
then I looked at her and she was like I
just moved a lot of energy in you
like she was like hold on to this
whatever
like some herb and I was like okay
like
my friend sat I mean the same sound this
is where I just sound like a [__]
goof but you don't I know everyone feels
like so wait I'm literally on the
medicine before this the smoke woman
came the real woman who helped me with
him apache's ceremony and I swear to God
my eyes are closed female Spirit came up
and then my friend sat down
male spirit
I get cleared
and and I look at my friend I go hey you
brought someone in with you and she goes
yeah it's my twin brother who died it's
just [__] where it's like I don't even
[__] with this right
like this is if you said nothing about
that you don't get that answer either of
course not but like damn
I don't know who the one the who the
this first woman was
twin brother who died [__] yeah like who
she's like he attached to me last night
it was her birthday okay so this is
going to be a very interesting question
we're gonna wrap up here but now this is
your first time here I ask everybody
advice to give to their 16 year old self
so 16 year old Neil Brennan's in the
[__] throes of Catholic High School
literally a sophomore probably around
that time sophomore junior and now after
everything we've just talked about with
Ayahuasca DMT all this stuff what advice
would you [__] give 16 year old Neil
Brennan
probably
try to control your impulses more
and like talk less
and be less
desperate like less desperate socially
and interactively with people like Les I
told somebody that I always felt like I
came into every interaction 20 points
down
and had to like
yeah it's like dude just
you're gonna be good it's all
it's the thing that
[__] works it all works out when one way
shape or form like it it all is cool
so just chill out and work hard and
pursue that but like
you're fine yeah you're fine yeah yeah
you're fine you're not gonna believe it
right
you may not feel fine but I promise you
you're fine
I promise you that's great advice
because you also you don't realize till
you get older like who knows what the
[__] [__] that person carried into
this conversation you know what I mean
everyone's going through their own
filters of insecurities and
uncertainties and all those things yeah
dude this has been a [__] fantastic
episode thank you very much
um plug and promote everything one more
time go brandon.com for the shows
no Charlotte
no Florida no Ohio and
um and uh blocks on the the podcast
platforms and YouTube great yep thank
you thank you but it's a great episode
thank you really appreciate it glad I
can do it um as always Ryan sickler.com
Ryan sickler on all your social media we
will talk to you all next week
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]